[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight it's a big week this is
the one-year anniversary of Robert
Muller's appointment as special counsel
to investigate Russian interference into
the 2016 election seems like a good time
to assess how's it going well the
investigation is costing millions of
dollars it's producing thousands and
thousands of hours of cable news
commentary our political system has been
brought to a virtual standstill we still
await the investigation its conclusions
one year in though what do we know so
far well certainly nothing we were
promised at the outset of the
investigation there's still no evidence
of any plot by the Trump campaign to
collude with the Russian government to
hack the presidency to beat Hillary
Clinton there's no evidence that Russia
hacked any vote totals for that matter
there still isn't any proof they were
behind the hacking of John Podesta's
emails we still even haven't seen
evidence they had anything to do with
the DNC hacking people have been charged
with crimes but only for behavior
totally unconnected to Trump's campaign
or because they allegedly lied to
Muller's investigative team in the case
of former national security adviser
Michael Flynn he apparently was charged
with a felony perjury crime even though
his FBI interviewers we just learned
didn't believe he was lying when they
spoke to him so a few people are having
their lives destroyed but for nothing
that we can see no collusion has been
found or even suggested doesn't mean we
haven't learned anything no we have
we've learned that when Russia did try
to influence the 2016 campaign they
weren't very good at it they spend a
small amount of money on online ads that
almost nobody saw most of them were in
states that had nothing to do with the
outcome of the race they weren't
competitive the ads weren't even all on
Trump's behalf somewhere against Trump
instead of backing a specific candidate
their greatest interest seems to have
been sowing chaos and disunity in the
American political system and on that
front of course mission accomplished
more than anything that we've learned
just how clueless the people who run
Washington DC are rather than accept the
fact that they created Donald Trump
themselves by abandoning and then coming
to despise the rest of the country they
run
they couldn't face that so they
concocted the Russia collusion story as
a way to sustain a world where they did
nothing wrong and they only lost because
their enemies betrayed this country to a
foreign power for more than a year
Russia was all they could talk about
because they certainly didn't want to
talk about the issues that got Trump
elected in the first place drug Odie's a
vanishing middle class their agenda of
literally replacing the people who live
in this country with immigrants they
don't talk about that but it hasn't been
working for most of Trump's presidency
Democrats have looked forward to the big
midterm wins that will give the control
of Congress once again that's the whole
point of all of this but it hasn't
worked their lead is dwindling it's now
within the margin of error they may not
win back the house at all it looks like
the Senate is going to be beyond their
reach why because the public has
recognized that the Russia investigation
is not what they said it was it is and
it has been from the beginning a witch
hunt created by a cabal frantic to keep
its hold on power